bien
d'abord quelques excuses avoir fait
attendre un peu mais on avait quelques
amendements à regarder
monsieur le premier ministre mes chers
collègues
nous avons été informés que le président
de la république envisagé sur
proposition de la première ministre de
nommer monsieur jean castex au poste de
président du conseil d'administration de
l' agence de financement des
infrastructures de transport de france
plus connu sous le nom de lafitte en
application de l'article
et de la procédure prévue au cinquième
alinéa de l'article 13 de notre
constitution
je promets me permettez moi tout d'abord
de vous souhaiter la bienvenue dans
cette maison que bien sûr vous
connaissez bien en effet pendant près de
deux ans de juillet 2020 âme et 2022
nous avons entretenu un dialogue
exigeant mais un dialogue respectueux
avec votre gouvernement à une période
évidemment masquée par la crise
sanitaire mais également par des textes
législatifs de première importance je
pense en particulier à la loi climat et
résilients du 22 août 2021 loi si chère
à notre commission notre commission vous
reçoit aujourd'hui non plus en qualité
d'ancien locataire de matignon mais deux
candidats pressentis pour exercer des
fonctions essentielles au sein d'une
agence qui joue un rôle stratégique pour
l'avenir des infrastructures de
transport dans notre pays je rappelle
que la fit est chargée de financer au
titre de l'état les grands projets
d'infrastructures de transport et de
mobilité mais aussi la part de l'état
dans les contrats de plan état région et
d'assurer les investissements de
régénération ou de sécurisation des
réseaux qu'ils soient routiers
ferroviaires et fluviaux après sa
nomination le nouveau président du
conseil d'administration de lafitte
héritera d'une agence pleinement intégré
dans un cadre d'intervention renouvelé à
la suite de l'adoption de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités sur laquelle
notre collègue didier mandelli qui en
était le rapporte reviendra sans doute
mais également un an après la signature
en avril de 20 mai 2021 de son premier
contrat d'objectifs et de performance ou
encore compte tenu de son implication
dans la mise en oeuvre du volet trop
sport du plan france relance toutefois
cette agence aurait également à faire
face à de nombreux défis je pense à sa
trajectoire financière qui est source
d'inquiétude comme le soulignait notre
collectif tabarot dans son dernier avis
budgétaires et plus globalement au choix
que nous ferons collectivement pour
réussir la décarbonation du secteur des
transports secteur des transports qui a
forcément d'importantes conséquences sur
le financement des infrastructures qui
sont dédiés et donc sur le coeur de
métier de la fit autant de points sur
lesquels notre commission sera
particulièrement vigilante je ne pas que
notre collègue didier mandelli qui était
désigné la semaine dernière par notre
commission rapporteur pour préparer
cette audition vous interrogera sur un
certain nombre de sujets sujets qui sont
au coeur des préoccupations de lafitte
pour ma part je souhaiterais vous
entendre sur les principaux objectifs
que vous fixé à vous même et à la fuite
si vous prenez la tête de l'aj ans en
2018 christophe béchu nous indiquait que
ces trois priorités était l'efficacité
la soutenabilité et la transparence
quels seront les vôtres avant de vous
laisser la parole je vous rappelle mes
chers collègues que cette audition
publique sera suivi d'un vote vote pour
lequel les délégations de vote ne sont
pas autorisés seuls les sénateurs
présents physiquement pour y prendre
part à bulletin secret le dépouillement
aura lieu à l'heure à l'issue de cette
audition
simultanément avec nos collègues de la
commission du développement durable de
l'aménagement du territoire de
l'assemblée nationale qui vous ont
entendu ce matin en audition sans plus
attendre je vous sais de la parole
monsieur le premier ministre pour nous
présenter votre candidature ce qui la
motive et la façon nous vendons vous
envisagez de diriger cette agence face
aux grands défis que je viens d'évoquer
je vous souhaite la parole de ce premier
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur président se
reporter mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et et les sénateurs donc
merci de m'accueillir ce matin pour cet
exercice dans vous avez rappelé le cadre
j'ai effectivement comme vous l'avez
indiqué été sollicité pour prendre
monsieur christophe béchu ayant été
nommés membres du gouvernement la
présidence de l'agencé de financement
des infrastructures de transport
je suis tout à fait honnête avec votre
mission je n'y avais pas spontanément
pensé mais je suis tout aussi honnête en
me disant que ça m'a tout aussi
spontanément vivement intéressé
pourquoi parce que et je crois que ça ne
vous surprendra pas ceux les sujets en
tout cas qu'elle traite de vous avez
rappelé les grandes lignes me paraît
sans en cohérence avec ce que j'ai
toujours pensé ce que j'ai ce que j'ai
toujours fait mon intérêt très marqué
pour la la question des transports qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui mobilité supérieure
si
elle était créée aujourd'hui peut-être
importerait où le mot mobilité
apparaitra aux antilles train vous savez
quelle date de d'il ya une 2004 2005
donc oui je suis effectivement
extrêmement intéressé par par cette
fonction parce que au delà de mes goûts
personnels finalement n'ont pas une
grande importance je pense comme vous
monsieur blanc que les sujets qui
relèvent de des prérogatives de cette
agence sont essentiels ils le sont bien
sûr pour la transition écologique ils le
sont pour la compétitivité économique
une leçon pour l'équité et le
développement des territoires auxquels
je sais le sénat particulièrement
attaché et ils le sont aussi tout
seulement pour la vie quotidienne de
millions de nos concitoyens
ceci posé
je permettais ben chaplin de de bien
rappelé est un établissement public de
l'état
vous avez dit qu'un rôle stratégique
majeur
cet établissement public de l'état c'est
à dire que les choix sur la nature des
investissements leur contenu
les modes de financement les ressources
qui doivent être mises en place en face
de ce soir la relève des autorités
démocratiques du gouvernement n'a vu que
de la représentation nationale est
évidemment je voulais dire votre
commission que j'ai parfaitement
conscience de ce que j'ai j'ai donc
changé de rôle et si bien entendu ma
nomination se trouve est confirmée
je ne serai plus en état de prendre des
décisions qui appartiennent à l'autorité
politique légitime
je dis ça puisque vous venez de le dire
j'arrive de l'assemblée nationale où
j'ai participé exactement même exercice
est bon beaucoup de questions
s'adressait en fait à l'ancien premier
ministre normal bien entendu ça va
d'autres d'ailleurs évidemment
l'occasion de discuter des des actions
que nous avons conduite dans ce domaine
des mobilités précisément la première
chose que je je veux dire dans ce propos
introductif c'est que
cette agence qui a eu l'histoire que
vous connaissez bien que ça collait bien
voulait rappeler présent longeau
nombreux avis ont été émis
sur ses interventions sur son rôle sur
sa gestion sur sa gouvernance
bon cette agence a est monté en maturité
je veux rendre hommage d'ailleurs je
saisis cette opportunité à christophe
béchu qui l'a qui la présidait depuis
depuis quelques années et qui a pu
mettre en oeuvre les axes prioritaires
que vous avez rappelé à l'instant et
si l'on regarde de la période tout à
fait récente ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle je le dire pour les
infrastructures transport autant que
pour l' agence c'est que le niveau de
ses engagements le niveau des dépenses
effectives réalisé à n'a jamais été
aussi élevé dans la certes pas très
longue histoire de cette agence afin
d'aller dans les 15
dernières années
on peut dire que en tout cas
la première partie de là l'homme que
vous avez cités de sa trajectoire
financière dont l'agencé par le sommet
l'un des bras armé a été grosso modo
respecter et je me plais pour le coup a
souligné qu' au moins sur les exercices
2020 2021 et 2022 en cours d'exécution
le plan de relance comme vous le savez
il ya beaucoup contribué j'avais rendu
en septembre 2020 un certain nombre
d'arbitrages vous le savez et et sur les
7 milliards 2,7 milliards que le plan de
relance a décidé de consacrer aux
mobilités un peu plus de trois ans vont
transiter par les comptes de l'agent ce
qui évidemment lui a donné des moyens
d'intervention supplémentaire en même
temps que cela assainit sa trésorerie et
permis comme le sénat a d'ailleurs
constaté de diminuer ou de résorber
ces impayés qui s'étaient accumulées bon
donc le l'on peut dire aussi toujours
par rapport à la l'homme que ben la
priorité
fixé sur le transport ferroviaire avait
surtout les transports décarbonés les
mobilités douces et c'est la priorité
fixée par le législateur a été respectée
par par l' agence
la priorité se souvient souvient de
commission durant et c'est la
réorientation consistant à dire que j'ai
un peu fait évoluer on y reviendra
priorité aux infrastructures existantes
notamment en matière ferroviaire
a été grosso modo là encore accomplie
puisque en 2021 dernier exercice clos 45
% des crédits de paiement de lagence ont
été consacrés aux infrastructures
existantes et à leur régénération ce qui
reste encore beaucoup à faire non les
investissements bref dans ce domaine par
l'agenge et par d'autres créneaux mais
c'est l'argent ce qui nous intéresse ont
été accrus mais vous avez raison jean
vient tout de suite à l'essentiel nous
avons il y a encore beaucoup à faire pas
même vous le savez que le cej a pu
parler dans un rapport qu'il m'avait
rendu en avril ou mai dernier récemment
d'un mur d'investissements on sait qu'on
a fait beaucoup
beaucoup sujet de régénération de
petites lignes ferroviaires mais il nous
reste à faire bon
en fait nous avons la chance mais bien
au delà d'elle vous le savez trois
échanges
de court terme
qui se présente à nous qui vont être
l'occasion de débats sûrement de choix
politiques forts que vous évoquez dans
votre intervention liminaire
je ne sais pas exactement vous préciser
qu en emea peut pas au même moment il
faudra finaliser les volets mobilité des
contrats de plan état région sujet
majeur compte tenu des compétences dont
dispose de région sur le sujet des
mobilités que le sénat connaît
parfaitement d'autant que nous avons
accru avec la loi
donc ça c'est la perspective de la fin
de l'année à peu près la même échéance
le conseil d'orientation investissement
va rendre un nouveau rapport ainsi que
c'est prévu et tout ça va préparer la
révision
que la loi prévoyait elle-même 200
trajectoire financière qui est prévu
pour vous le savez à la moitié amis
2023 bon on sait que déjà les coûts
partie si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
représente de l'ordre de 14 milliards
d'euros mais on sait aussi que si on si
on additionne les ja des premières
remontées des contrats de plan état
région dans leurs volets mobilité
ça ira au delà d'autant vous le savez
que
le gouvernement avait pris la décision
d'accélérer un certain nombre de projets
je pense notamment à des lignes à grande
vitesse dont le la fif tel le le support
fait ainsi donc par rapport à votre
question initiale monsieur le président
mon premier mon premier rôle sera
à la place qui est la mienne fois mais
de préparer ces échéances majeures qui
vont donc supposer qu'on s'accordent sur
un tendancielle
d'investissement pour la période à venir
dans le sujet des mobilités évidemment
de déterminer ceux d'entre eux qui
seront supportés ou payés par l' agence
qui nous rend ouvrira à des arbitrages
sur le panier de ressources ma
recommandation au gouvernement et à la
pente à sa seule ce sera surtout de
garder un panier de ressources mêlant de
la fiscalité affecter des produits de
redevances et une partie de crédits
budgétaires de garder aussi une
structure qui vous permettent de gérer
le temps long c'est à dire la
pluriannualité qui s'attache à ces
projets d'investissement qui sont par
construction très long trop long compte
tenu de nos procédures bien connu par le
sénat et donc j'allais dire les
fondements le soft vous rappeliez les
priorités qu avait dégagé
christophe béchu resteront les mêmes je
passe une fois accéléré
sera axée ce sont des choix difficiles
parce que renvoyant à des questions de
soutenabilité des finances publiques
mais pour l'essentiel n'est pas besoin
de vous le rappeler nous avons affaire à
des dépenses d'investissement
qui peuvent avoir un retour sur
investissement fort y compris en terme
de fonctionnement là sans doute encore
de ce point de vue là les projets
devront être améliorés de la même façon
j'ai lu comme ça nous beaucoup d'entre
vous les rapports de la cour des comptes
sur
lagence nous reviendront peut-être sur
le principe même de son existence mais
sur sa gestion sur sa transparence des
progrès ont été faits il ya eu un coq
qui a été signée vous y faisiez allusion
pas encore forcément entrer dans l'état
et là je hais pas que je découvre le
sujet mais je ne suis évidemment pas
président mais simplement modeste
candidat mais je vois que là aussi il y
a des marges d'amélioration et je pense
que la force de cette agence pour
conclure mon propos introductif façon
dont je vois mon rôle puisque c'était
votre question d'abord c'est peut-être à
la fois de gérer la pluriannualité et la
transversalité il y à des parlementaires
qui siègent il ya des représentants des
collectivités territoriales
dans le même des mobilités comme dans
d'autres les compétences sont partagés
il faut vivre ça et en faire une force
il faut aussi que le fait qu'il s'agit
d'un établissement public de face en
aucune manière obstacle au contrôle et
la transparence vis-à-vis du parlement
et de la représentation nationale c'est
donc un engagement que je prends devant
vous non qu il y ait matière à critique
en matière m'a fait je pense qu'on peut
encore s'améliorer surtout encore une
fois si nous considérons que les efforts
doivent être accrus et les moyens
amplifié voilà donc j'ai une vision
extrêmement
pragmatique de cette fonction il faut il
faudra essayer de maintenir les effort
important qu'on a fait et qui sont
encore insuffisants il faudra donc
stabiliser un panier de ressources pour
nous permettre d'atteindre nos objectifs
et veiller comme toujours au meilleur
possible
emploi de ces deniers publics
merci pour ces ses propos et ses
précisions et ses réponses aux questions
je vais donner la parole à notre
apportera diémoz délit
merci monsieur le président ce prêt
ministre et monsieur le candidat à la
présidence de la fuite je dois vous
avouer en préambule que lorsque
christophe béchu été nommé au
gouvernement nous sommes posé la
question à quelques-uns clips notamment
de la personnalité ou la personne qui
pourrait lui succéder à la présidence de
la fit
interlocuteur est évidemment important
pour le sénat et sur ces questions
mobilité et je dois vous avouer que
c'est pas votre nom qui est arrivé est
évidemment en tête de nos suppositions
même si et je pense que vous avez pu
traduire votre intérêt et votre
appétence pour le sujet
faut mettre à votre crédit 100 me de
réalisations en premier ministre à la
fois une ligne si chère au coeur de
françois et et votre dû perpignan paris
régis et puis vous avez et c'est là vous
avez gagné
le coeur de tous ceux qui s'intéressent
aux mobilités vous avez passé une nuit
dans le train paris nice en train
couchettes donc c'est un
oui mais en tout cas celui là était
médiatisé
donc ça vous donne du crédit pour cette
présidence voilà plus plus sérieusement
la fit est en quelque sorte c'est un mot
vous avez utilisé également le bras armé
de l'état en matière de financement des
infrastructures de transport mobilité au
sens large là l'homme a permis de lui
donner une visibilité en termes de
trajectoire sur ses dépenses sur la
période 2010 9 2027 j'avais utilisé
d'ailleurs en tant que rapporteur de la
home le mot sanctuariser les recettes de
la fit et même si nous avons constaté
évidemment au fil du temps que c'est
cette trajectoire était théorique qu'il
fallait l'ajuster en permanence puisque
de nouvelles missions ont été attribués
à la fuite je pense bien sûr au chantier
long turin
l'infrastructure du canal seine nord qui
nous avait valu
convocation d'une réunion en urgence 24
heures pour permettre la signature le
lendemain par le président de la
république sur site avec les élus locaux
vous avez évoqué le plan de relance
également les mobilités douces donc des
missions nouvelles je me crée dans mon
dernier paragraphe également une
nouvelle mission confiée à lafitte j'ai
constaté bien sûr en tant que membre du
conseil d'administration de cette agence
jusqu'en 2021 date à laquelle j'ai été
remplacé avantageusement par mon
excellent collègue philippe dabat
tabarot ici présents donc moi je sois je
vous interromps su de manière à ses
prospects prospective sur votre vision
du rôle de lagence le président a évoqué
également le président de cette agence
et est également membre de droit du
conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures qui étaient là encore
pérenniser et créé officiellement dans
le cadre de la l'homme
la fuite at elle vocation selon vous qu
en quelque sorte à sortir de son rôle
d'exécutant à être davantage intégrés
dans les décisions en matière
d'infrastructures de transport
évidemment avec le ministère de les
ministères de le ministère de tutelle
comment voyez-vous l'articulation entre
ces deux entités un conseil
d'orientation
structures existent qui exécute en lien
avec le ministère évidemment ensuite je
souhaiterais vous entendre sur la
manière dont vous appréhendé un temps
que évidemment potentiel futur président
du conseil a misé à sion d'appliquer
certaines des décisions qui ont parfois
été prise lorsque vous étiez premier
ministre
là encore certains arbitrages ont pu
créer la surprise voire susciter
l'incompréhension je pense notamment la
priorité claire vous l'avez évoqué
également qu'il ya d'abord été donnée
aux transports du quotidien avant
l'annoncé de la création de nouvelles
lignes de tgv par le président de la
république lui-même début de mandat
c'était plus de tgv
donc ma troisième question concerne les
recettes de la fuite c'était évoqué
également à plusieurs reprises ou neuf
états j'imagine que plusieurs de mes
collègues vont poser des questions sur
ce sujet la plupart des recettes de
l'agent sont prélevés sur le transport
routier redevance externe et bénéficie
non seulement à la route bien sûr mais
également tous les autres modes de
transport je pense évidemment au
ferroviaire mais surtout fluviale qui
avait ses moyens largement multipliées
depuis quelques années plusieurs de ses
recettes sont versées par le secteur
routier autoroutier
aussi à du point de vue de la fit
comment envisagez vous la perspective de
l'arrivée à échéance des contrats de
concession qui priverait de fait
mécaniquement la fuite d'une grande part
de ses ressources et enfin la dernière
question porte sur une nouveauté pour l'
agence sur la politique de gestion
d'adaptation du trait de côte dans les
territoires littoraux
pour laquelle les agences participent au
financement d'études locales à la maison
n'a de solution à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros de crédits de paiement dans le
plf 2022 c'était une nouveauté il s'agit
aujourd'hui seul levier permettant à
l'état de cofinancer avec des taurillons
30 à 80% des opérations de lutte contre
l'érosion côtière
alors que la loi climat et résilience à
créer de nouvelles obligations
applicables aux collectivités la mise en
oeuvre de stratégies locales
d'adaptation impose un co financement
des mesures de protection et
d'adaptation bien plus élevé je pars
refaire l'état du fonds barnier de ses
affectations
le cofinancement de la cartographie
c'est une petite partie de ce qui
conviendrait de prendre en charge quel
regard portez-vous sur cette
problématique qui touche des milliers de
collectivités locales et donc de nos
concitoyens ils soient
habités en chef d'entreprise externe et
je pense notamment question de
délocalisation de certaines activités
elle vous prêt à demander dans le cadre
des arbitrages budgétaires une
augmentation des crédits de la fuite sur
ce point et de fat étendre ses missions
et ses besoins bien sûr en personnel
pour traiter ces questions spécifiques
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
candidat les quelques questions je
souhaitais vous poser en tant que
rapporteur mais je laisse tout de suite
la parole mais merci c'est n'importe
quoi je vais vous laisser répondre à
notre rapporteur et puis à présent à
part la fidh tabarot qu elle vous répond
pierre présidera par l'a34 collègues qui
sont qui ont beaucoup de questions je
vous en prie
merci je président
comment je vois l'articulation avec eux
qui étaient un peu de gouvernance et
institutionnels
j'ai très franc avec vous comme vous je
vois pas trop fait joaillier jeu j'ai
jamais siégé au ca oui je vais voir bon
je je
je vois à peu près quelle architecture
une agence de financement le coi qui lui
cristallise le débat sur les choix
d'investissement
ce qui éclaire encore une fois c'est que
il va falloir que je trouve comme
toujours comme avait dû le faire tous
mes prédécesseurs le bon équilibre entre
ce qui relève des autorités légitimes
pour rendre des arbitrages
sur votre dernière question vuli ben oui
bien sûr je souhaite qu'on améliore ou
qu on accroît ses crédits sur têt coop
la fin de chacun de pouvoir me dire mais
ce vous croyez pas qu'il faut mettre de
crédit sur la rn temps sur la petite
ligne ferroviaire temps et cetera si je
vous réponds non nous votre babeau moi
c'est embêtant mais le réveil avec le
sujet n'est pas n'est pas la fête j'ai
le il faut à la fois
que je veille scrupuleusement respect
des décisions qui doivent être prises tj
team et en même temps que je trouve ma
place pour poser parce que si j'ai
accepté d'être candidat et si le
candidat par hasard devenait président
mais je je compte se jouer le seul
reporter mon rôle à part entière y
compris au sein du coi y compris si
c'était le sous jacent de votre question
concourir à une réflexion sur
l'éventuelle efficience de 7 ans en
amont ma j'arrive je vois là je me suis
déjà entretenu avec le député qui
préside le seui
gouvernement le sujet l'a envoyé c'est
déjà de voir ouanane est sûre le cpr et
volet mobilité je sais où j'avais laissé
le le dossier dont je vais regarder où
va alors je ne fais pas de réponse a
priori tout c'est que ça marche ça
marche le mieux possible bon et que
sinon encore une fois je serai pas là
je crois que j'ai quelques crédits au
delà de ce que vous dites est de la
ligne par perpignan registre on a quand
même remis pas mal d'argent dans les
infrastructures
évidemment si vous commencez à dire la
bonne question suivante ah oui mais si
on compare à l'allemagne si on compare
c'est vrai et c'est vrai bon mais si on
compare ces trente années passées c'est
plus voilà donc laissé d'affaires du
verre à moitié plein ou à moitié vide ou
à ski etc la commission compte vous
qu'il faut continuer bon continuer quoi
mais alors là voyez je sors l'assemblée
si tout ça est public alors je si les
intrigues oui vous êtes un grand
amoureux du train mais vous avez fait
beaucoup pour les routes normalement
c'est des gens qui me reprochaient pas
les routes et alors quand on parlait du
travail mais alors il ya le tout tgv
vous avez relancé le tgv bon
de ce que je connais moi je vous dis mon
sentiment en tant que deux candidats en
tant qu ancien élu en tant qu'ancien
premier ce la france étant la france il
ya une priorité claire qui est la
décarbonation des modes transport qui
sont des mobilités douces adapté serment
mais je considère qu'on a besoin des
lignes fines du territoire de la grande
vitesse des routes
notamment dans le milieu rural bon il
faut faire des choix des priorités mais
les les lgv j'ai envie un peu là aussi
mais je suis prêt à répondre à votre
question
vous avez cité à bon droit le président
la république mais votre serviteur
revendique une forte implication
je le dis pour effectivement le quai les
choix qui a été fait c'était de dire on
va d'abord régénérer avant de faire de
la grande vitesse en eux pour suivre la
grande vitesse corps on a augmenté les
crédits régénération il dans le plan de
relance
on a encore plus mis le paquet donc je
le moment me paraissait venu pour
rouvrir d'autant que j'avais des
collectivités territoriales les
présidents de régions concernées
aquitaine occitanie paca qui me poussait
qui m'interpellait donc fait que on
apprécie jean le sénat l'icaunais visant
à accélérer les trois grands projets le
plus urgent eux le rappel et angers
pesos pourquoi parce que je rappel c'est
le seul qui est déclaré d'utilité
publique
accélérer les procédures sur montpellier
perpignan et la lgv paca
donc oui et ce évidemment ça les rassure
les la séquence des crédits mais je
pense qu'il faut je le dis à la fois
poursuivre l'effort de régénération et b
vont peut-être seul élu du sud kivu
parle mais je ne sais pas expliquer aux
habitants de toulouse aux habitants de
montpellier aux habitants de nice qui
n'auraient pas droit à la grande vitesse
alors que rennes strasbourg c'était il
ya aussi une question d'équité
d'acceptabilité des politiques publiques
et des équilibres des territoires qui me
paraît elle se rend indispensable
les recettes de tva à y revenir on peut
les prendre une par une je vous redis ma
conviction peu et vous savez tout ce qui
s'est passé c'est rien avaler
quelques aléas on va dire entre les
amendes radars qui ont au moins rentrer
parce qu'ils aient dit les jaunes a été
créé la taxe ce billet d'avion que nous
avons je crois sagement différé compte
tenu de la grave crise que l'aco vide a
entraîné sur ce secteur vont on a
effectivement vous les 10 millions à
porter des perspectives sur la taxe se
seraient produits pétroliers qui
normalement devrait peut être
défavorable
justement parce que nous en décarbonés
les modes de transport donc là et il va
falloir
réfléchir à tout ça et je suis très
heureux si vous permettez que vous y
ayez mis là au milieu l'arrivée à
échéance des contrats de conception
n'est pas évoquée dans mon propos
similaires je rappelle sénatrice atteint
ici présents sauf erreur de ma part que
la première condition qu'arrivent agen
c'est 2031 comme ce n'est pas certain si
j'étais lui que je sois encore président
de la fif en 2031 mais en tout cas je
pense que nous gagnerions je compte bien
que l'âge ainsi contribuer préparer
cette charge y compris dans les
questions relatives aux recettes y
compris de la question et heroes et
voilà et sur le trait de côte oui j'ai
vu j'ai découvert faut des rétais
relisant les bilans d'activités de
lagence qu'elle s'occupait de sujets
voilà aussi je pense qu'à travailler
quoi la fif jusqu'où la fif jusqu'où je
n'ai pas de réponse a priori
mais il faudra que je sois en mesure
après discussion les uns les autres
commencez par le ministère de cadrer
dans le cadre des ce tunnel qui est
devant nous jusqu'à l'été 2023 les
priorités de cet établissement
merci pour vos réponses j'ai donné la
parole à philippe tabarot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre candidat si certains
ont pu s'étonner de cette proposition
formulée par le président de la
république ce n'est pas notre cas ici
sur les bandes cette commission nous
connaissons votre appétence où nous
l'avait rappelé pour les questions
mobilité vos engagements par exemple
pour les petites lignes ferroviaires
malgré un contrat de performance très
décevant signé à la fin de ce
quinquennat nous aurons l'occasion d'en
reparler avec les collègues mais je peux
en témoigner personnellement je sais le
rôle prépondérant qui fut le vôtre que
ce soit pour la réouverture du train de
nuit paris nice dont a parlé didier et
le dossier de la ligne nouvelle provence
côte d'azur en tant qu'administrateur
après l'excellent didier mandelli je
constate que la fit pointé par le passé
par la cour des comptes et vous l'avez
dit également est sur le chemin du
redressement
et la transparence pour autant vous
rencontrer à mon sens de défis si nous
faisons confiance lors de du vote qui se
déroulera dans quelques instants le
premier défi et vous l'avez très
justement dit didier mandé lille a
évoqué également c'est réaffirmer le
rôle permanent du président de laffitte
au conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures en effet pour ne pas
réitérer les erreurs du passé sur les
difficultés de financement sur le canal
seine europe ça a été évoqué ou sur le
lyon turin qui ont été oubliés entre
guillemets des trajectoires budgétaires
ensuite pour affronter l'avenir en
acteur majeur et non plus en spectateur
tiroir caisse qui essaient de payer la
note d'un menu qu'il n'a pas choisie en
intégralité
à mon sens le deuxième défi également
affronter pour vous et pour l'équipe qui
vous accompagne au niveau administratif
faible équipe d'ailleurs besoin de tp
supplémentaires je referme la parenthèse
laffitte est une agence avec des
dépenses certaine et des recettes
incertaines comme le disait votre
prédécesseur très souvent il faut avouer
qu'il l'a été particulièrement elle a
été particulièrement malchanceuse
vis-à-vis des recettes qui lui ont été
attribués vous le venez de le dire la
privatisation des autoroutes alors que
leurs bénéfices devaient financer à
l'époque l'agent ce tout au début
l'abandon de l'écotaxe qui était censé
également lui bénéficié
je reviens pas sur le fond de l'abandon
de l'écotaxe chers collègues bretons
c'est simplement une constatation je ne
dis pas que c'est bien ou mal chauffés
la constatation je vous ai vu dodeliner
et la crise sanitaire qui a mis un coup
d'arrêt au transport aérien alors que
l'âge ans s'était vu affecter juste
avant la taxe de solidarité sur les
billets aériens et pourtant la question
des recettes est la mère de toutes les
batailles et la soutenabilité financière
de lagence où l'avait évoquée -dont je
le souhaite vous allez prendre la
présidence nous inquiète alors ma
question est toute simple comment
allez-vous avec des recettes incertaines
comme les amendes radars ou en passe de
se tarir comme la paix icpe franchir le
fameux mur
d'investissements dont parle le coi que
nous appelons de nos voeux pour la
mobilité de tous nos territoires
je peux mieux dit je vous laisse
répondre merci beaucoup
je partage évidemment tout ce que tout
ce que vous avez dit
je n'ai pas évidemment qualité pour vous
dire voilà on va créer de recettes
nouvelles je avoir quelques idées mais
bon je pense qu'en méthode me
semble-t-il le premier exercice et il
faut vraiment qu'on s'accorde d'abord
sur un niveau de dépenses
sur ce qu'on va faire si fort pour bleu
clair il faut réviser la trajectoire de
la longue
si on aime les transports évidemment
sous-entend révisé à la hausse bon
enfin se passionnaient mme les
transports c'est si on tient compte des
besoins réels qui s'exprime notamment en
termes de décarbonation en termes de
mobilité en termes de de tous les sujets
que vous connaissez
et ensuite
voilà il faut il faudra arrêter un
panier de recettes sans exclure le
recours à des crédits budgétaires mais
c'est ce qui se passe toujours à la fin
des fins sont les crédits budgétaires
qui vont faire la jointure
jeu parce que nous devons être
imaginatif et trouver une ressource
affectée parce que encore une fois
finalement c'est ce qui fait
l'originalité
du dispositif qui a été bâti il a connu
des aléas
[Musique]
je me suis amusé à relire pas ce que
vous dites ouidah aujourd'hui et ça va
on y arrive mais on est très inquiet
pour la suite
je partage ce diagnostic mais il a
souvent été posée j'ai regardé voyez des
travaux sur la fif datant de 2008 2010
on disait déjà ça elle est toujours là
on a su prouver un des solutions dans
toi ma préconisations pour être très
clair avec vous c'est de dire essayons
de trouver un panier de recettes avec
des recettes affectées et le reste ce
sera des crédits budgétaires set ça va
être un sujet majeur être un sujet
majeur voilà donc le choix politique
fort
v donné la passion le pardon excusez moi
je reviens parce que là aussi relais les
petites lignes enfin le contrat signé
avec la sncf avant le départ oui bien
sûr qu' il faudrait on aurait pu faire
mieux je rappelle un seul chiffre m
issue du dernier rapport
de la cour sur les petites lignes
ferroviaires c'est ce dont nous parlons
moyenne annuelle je peux remonter à
mathusalem
2015-2018 60 millions par an
2015-2018 moyenne annuelle
2020-2022 180 millions par an
il faut plus de 180 millions par an dont
de tacna fin
puissions-nous bien maintenir déjà
c'était fort en faveur des petites
lignes elles sont en tête de gondole des
négociations cpr que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure mais vous le savez très bien
merci la parole était la chronique
monsieur le président sur le premier
ministre candidat donc sur votre
candidature oui le rôle de cet agent
c'est capital ses moyens humains sont
réduits je vois ces quatre équivalents
temps plein et donc sa présidence soit
confiée à une personnalité d'un poids
incontestable pourra évidemment être un
atout sur les enjeux moi je suis de
l'agglomération de strasbourg dont la
situation permet bien d'apprécier les
différences de trajectoire de politique
de mobilité transports entre nos pays et
nos voisins pourtant confrontés aux
mêmes impératifs décarbonation vitalité
des territoires modernisation et pour ce
qui est justement on l'évoquait de la
soutenabilité de la pérennité des
financements y a pas photo vraiment nous
voisins suisses et allemands travaillent
sur vraiment dû pluriannuel sécurisé
avec des recettes consistante notamment
on l'évoquait la contribution du
transport camionné donc j'abonde nous a
mis un petit pot l'eau à la bouche avec
l'idée d'une nouvelle recette ressources
affectées mais donc comment selon vous
mieux faire converger dans une même
durabilité recettes et dépenses et
justement pour des investissements de
développement durable de décarbonation
la comparaison aussi avec nos voisins
mais en valeur nos retards oui oui vous
avez raison le ferroviaire est mieux
traité ces derniers temps même si le
retour de coûteux et discutable protège
projet tgv le poids du lyon-turin pose
problème mais le contrat de performance
qu'a été signée discrètement ne
construit pas la trajectoire du
doublement de part modale il y manque
comme au minimum 1 milliard par an et la
contribution de l'état via la fit pour
laisser per est ce qu'elle sera à la
hauteur des ambitions de développement
des transports collectifs urbains je
pense par exemple sur l'eurométropole de
strasbourg ont construit très bien avec
le grand est un réseau express
métropolitains pas simplement du
ferroviaire mais aussi du réseau
cyclable structure et je crois que c'est
là que se joue la décongestion recul de
l'autosolisme le pouvoir d'achat aussi
la qualité de l'air
merci je vais donner la parole à
stéphane demi
vous donne la parole à 5 de nos
collègues et puis vous remercier
globalement merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre vous l'avez
dit le ferroviaire et restera un acteur
clé du verdissement de nos transports et
de la libération contre le réchauffement
climatique mais j'ai deux questions ma
première question concerne l'entretien
et la rénovation des infrastructures
existantes
les grands projets ont toujours
l'attrait de la nouveauté il vampirise
souvent l'attention les promesses et
souvent les crédits également mais il
est souvent plus urgent de maintenir
l'existant vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
propos préliminaires en évoquant le
chiffre de 45 % je suis sénateur des
hauts de france et un usager régulier de
la ligne amiens paris ou plus exactement
j'essaie de l'être n'aurait notre région
est en dernière place des classements de
régularité on l'entend souvent à travers
la voix colérique de notre président de
région et xavier bertrand en tout cas
tout cela ne réjouit pas les les usagers
ils sont 200 milles par jour de picardie
et des hauts de france d'une façon
générale qui sont massés dans des trains
plein à craquer sans réseau sans
chauffage sans clim et parfois sans
lumière et les récente canicule ont
encore compliqué la situation les
infrastructures ferroviaires est en
sensible aux fortes chaleurs les rails
et les caténaires se déformant sous
l'effet de la température sont contents
sans compter pardon les les incendies
sur le bord des voix qui impacte
directement la circulation des trains
bref les infrastructures ferroviaires ne
sont pas prévues pour faire face à de
telles températures
donc ma première question c'est en tant
que président de laffitte feriez-vous de
l'entretien de la rénovation des lignes
existantes une priorité au même titre
que leur nécessaire adaptation au
changement climatique ma deuxième
question est beaucoup plus courte quand
on regarde larchitecture des sociétés de
projet j'ai beaucoup suivi depuis 1997
le dossier de seine nord europe on voit
que dans des projets tels que bordeaux
toulouse pour un exemple que vous avez
cités tout à l'heure il s'agit des pics
locaux que l'état dote de recettes
affectées et je pense spécifiquement à
la taxe d'aménagement sur les bureaux
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est épique
locaux cette architecture sera désormais
celles des modèles que deux réalisations
de tous les grands futurs projets
merci je vais donner la parole à marc
table de cédric
et puis après hervé gillé
merci président monsieur le premier
ministre il se trouve que je suis membre
du conseil national du bruit donc ma
question portera en réalité sur
l'essentiel des nuisances sonores et
vibratoires que le secteur
des transports peut peut causer
lagence participe actuellement au
financement est évidemment de nombreuses
études d'infrastructures de rénovation
dax existants mais ne semble pas avoir
véritablement de stratégie précise en la
matière avec des financements et des
actions spécifiques et alloué à ce sujet
là les enjeux sont pourtant importants
le coût pour les français de la mauvaise
qualité de l'environnement sonore a été
chiffré par l'ademe à 147 milliards
d'euros pour 2021 dont 106 milliards au
bruit des transports les transports du
quotidien comme les grandes lignes sont
concernées nous avons tous dans nos
territoires des exemples en la matière
moi qui suis sénatrice des yvelines je
peux vous citer énormément de cas où
c'est un véritable fléau pour beaucoup
de riverains autour des transports donc
l'aménagement véritablement de
l'infrastructure donc même à mes deux
questions sont très simples et très très
rapide pensez vous que la fist sous
votre mandat doivent faire de la lutte
contre les nuisances sonores un axe de
travail avec une stratégie dédiée et
pensez vous qu'elle dispose des moyens
suffisant pour agir en la matière je
vous remercie
merci la parole à hervé gillé puis à
marty fille après je vous propose est
vrai bon
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention mais on a encore
beaucoup de difficultés à avoir une
trajectoire financière véritablement au
niveau de la fuite ainsi pour l'exercice
2009 1,3 il est prévu deux milliards 7
180 millions d'euros précédemment bien
sûr c'était 3 milliards 4 milliards et
le plan de relance juppé au quai des
crédits du plan de relance qui vont être
reportées éventuellement sur l'exercice
2023 mais on a peu de lisibilité
aujourd'hui sur ces montants en tout cas
ces deux milliards sept cent
quatre-vingts sont inférieures au
montant de 2020 qui était le montant de
référence pourrait-on dire hors plan de
relance à 2 milliards 824 donc ya là une
interrogation qui est intéressante sur
les incertitudes en termes de recettes
ce sujet a été soulignée et donc c'est
un chantier visiblement auquel vous
allez aux attelé il ya une question
aujourd'hui sur les contributions et
notamment la contribution volonté des
sociétés d'autoroutes ou là il ya un
contentieux qui existerait toujours vous
l'avez pas évoquer donc si vous pouvez
nous apporter quelques éléments sur ce
sujet là enfin sur la question justement
de là l'homme des petites lignes et des
lignes d'équilibré au regard des lignes
grande vitesse ou du tgv ce qui est deux
choses différentes les lignes d'une part
et le tgv d'autre part en tout état de
cause même si vous portez ce projet avec
la région occitanie ce qui sera mis là
ne sera pas mis ailleurs de toute façon
or quand on parle de décarbonation la
décarbonation c'est avant tout sur le
transport du quotidien quoi qu'on en
pense donc en termes de priorités il ya
une véritable interrogation mais
concernant le gpso je voudrais vous
interroger une manière plus précise les
seuls engagements dont nous avons
entendu parler c'est bordeaux toulouse
mais c'est pas bordeaux dax or cette
ligne et ce gp son porte sur deux lignes
on est bien d'accord chers collègues
bordeaux-toulouse d'un côté bordeaux dax
pour la liaison vers l'espagne d'autre
part donc il semblerait que les seuls
engagements budgétaires même sur les
acquisitions foncières aujourd'hui
serait sur bordeaux toulouse et non pas
sur bordeaux dax il y à une un tronçon
de ligne commune au démarrage mais la
poursuite vers bordeaux dax elle reste
dans l'incertitude
enfin quand on parle également des
recettes et j'en terminerai là on est
aussi sur un modèle économique un mix
aux financiers qui s'appuie notamment
pour les lignes lgv sur des crédits
européens or au niveau des crédits
européens notamment sur le gpso nous
sommes en pleine incertitude la dernière
décision de la commission européenne a
retoqué les demandes de financement
d'études pour le coup les a reportées
aujourd'hui en tout cas il ya une
véritable incertitude or sur le gpso il
est attendu au moins 20 % de financement
européen a minima et ses 20% seront
gagés uniquement sur la ligne bordeaux
espagne et non pas bordeaux toulouse
donc quand on regarde les recettes d'une
manière générale les recettes s'apprécie
avec l'ensemble des participations
financières et pour le coup sur ce sujet
là il ya une véritable interrogation de
fonds je vous remercie
merci la parole est à mme martine
filleul
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
pardon je souhaitais vous poser deux
questions qui concernent les effets
réchauffement climatique
en effet d'année en année les épisodes
de canicule se multiplient avec pour
incidence d'entraîner de nombreuses
perturbations sur les réseaux de
transport
quand bien même le gouvernement se
décider enfin adopter des mesures
ambitieuses pour lutter activement
contre le réchauffement climatique et a
réellement endiguer son amplification
les scientifiques nous alertent déjà sur
les conséquences irrémédiables des
activités humaines sur l'environnement
et le climat
dès lors il semble nécessaire de tenir
compte de ces bouleversements dans les
investissements réalisés sur le réseau
de transport français par exemple
prendre en considération le
réchauffement climatique lors de
l'aménagement du réseau ferroviaire
nous-mêmes permettrait à la fois de
limiter les perturbations qui nuisent au
quotidien des français mais également de
diminuer les dépenses réalisées pour sa
maintenance cela passe entre autres et
pour exemple par le choix de matériaux
qui isole les composants électroniques
sensibles à la chaleur par l'adaptation
de la pose de rails pour anticiper les
dilatations de l'acier ou encore par
l'entretien de la végétation pour
limiter les risques d'incendié etc et
intense pardon j'ai pris ici l'exemple
du réseau ferroviaire mais je pourrais
bien décliner cette démonstration pour
les infrastructures routières les voies
navigables et autres aussi ma question
monsieur le premier ministre
est la suivante quelle stratégie avez
vous imaginé de mettre en oeuvre en fin
d'année sur la prise en compte du
réchauffement climatique dans les
investissements de cette agence pour les
différents réseaux de transports
français
ma deuxième question concerne
concerne le report modal et le canal
seine-nord en effet la question du
report modal s'impose à nous compte tenu
du réchauffement climatique est
cependant
voit bien que les choses ne sont ne se
font pas naturellement est loin de là si
je prends pour exemple la construction
du canal seine nord qui vise à
désengorger la d'une partie non
négligeable de son important trafic de
poids lourds permettant de rejeter ainsi
au moins de gaz à effet de serre
permettant de lutter contre les
inondations dans l'oise et de diminuer
le risque d'inondation mais également
d'avoir un axe permettant au port de
dunkerque et du havre de gagner en
attractivité
afin de concurrencer ceux de rotterdam
et anvers quatre plateformes
multimodales pardon multimodal figurait
dans le projet d'origine avec la
création donc deux ports intérieurs à
péronne noyon compiègne et cambrai au
final seulement deux vont pouvoir
bénéficier de dessertes ferroviaires et
routières les autres devant se contenter
d'une simple desserte routière pour des
raisons financières
aussi ma question est la suivante
monsieur le premier ministre
quelle stratégie à l'échelle globale
avez vous prévu de mettre en oeuvre
enfin afin d'inclure la prise en compte
des reports modaux dans les
investissements de votre agence pour les
différents réseau français de transport
merci je vais vous proposer de répondeur
cette première série de cinq questions
et puis je vends ma parole 2e série de
cinq questions
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
les reprend dans l'ordre si vous voulez
bien
la première question qui m'a été posée
mais me conduit à évoquer le sujet avec
vous il y avait plusieurs questions à
votre intervention mais
la première parce que je n'ai pas fait
jusque là c'est celle des moyens humains
de l' agence dont je salue d'ailleurs la
secrétaire général qui est présente à
moi qui ai sont effectivement je donne
constat partagé vous l'avez d'ailleurs
évoqué
comment dire
mesure est compté
et même la cour des comptes d'air
puisqu'il a été évoquée pas dans ses
habitudes préconise renforcement des
moyens humains l'agent ce pour dire
vérité je je je vois même que le la
difficulté va au delà parce que
statutairement ça fonctionne je parle
sous votre contrôle madame la secrétaire
géant par des systèmes de mise à
disposition
qui du coup leur à ne pas forcément
attractif les emplois créés par la
structure ni le contenu travail et à la
faiblesse numérique s'ajoute un turnover
qui incontestablement un est trop rapide
et nuit sans doute à la performance
globale donc il ya un petit sujet je
veux pas en faire une question majeure
ici mais il ya sûrement une question que
je voudrais régler entre 4 et et qui est
de donner de façon raisonnable de façon
il s'agit pas de se lancer dans une
inflation l'emploi en tout cas une
ossature en termes de moyens de
fonctionnement et demain éventuellement
humains à l'agent je vous le dis parce
que je pense pas que j'aurai l'occasion
de le refaire
je rappelle je vous rappelle aussi
monsieur le sénateur que vous avez entre
autres sujets
cissé revient pas sur les comparaisons
internationales sur lesquels je me suis
déjà exprimé en vous donnant raison mais
vous avez insisté sur les transports
urbains transports collectifs urbains
qui est un vrai sujet là aussi les
moyens de l'agencé ont été accrus
notamment à la faveur du plan de relance
et du quatrième appel à projets non
j'avais personnellement annoncé les
résultats à tourcoing en 2021 et qui
avoisine le milliard d'euros plus des
opérations spécifiques style le le métro
de toulouse donc nul doute que là aussi
ces sujets seront au coeur des priorités
que nous devrons arrêter et que l'on
retrouvera dans les volets mobilité des
contrats de plan
le pour le port pour vous monsieur le
sénateur est bon et j'ai j'entends je
vis tout ce que vous avez dit sur la
régularité des trains fait il y a aussi
un sujet dont je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
relèvent agences mais effectivement nous
mettons beaucoup d'argent l'état les
régions citées dans le système
ferroviaire effectivement nous devons
veiller les autorités organisatrices
doivent veiller auprès d'amas cfa la
qualité du service rendu virons tout ça
se tient chaque un sexe il y à un niveau
insuffisant dans les infrastructures et
dans la maintenance
c'est une des raisons de la dégradation
de la qualité du service une autre
sénatrice a aussi évoqué la question de
du changement climatique et de la
résilience des
matériels à cette évolution mais
évidemment il y a aussi des des
exigences qui s'imposent à la sncf en sa
qualité de gestionnaire des des réseaux
et des voix sur toutes les questions que
vous avez
souligné
la structuration un epic locaux puisque
donc il ya eu plusieurs questions qui
sont venus qui tournent notamment autour
de sympa que de gps au mans tout cas des
grandes infrastructures parce que
effectivement c'est une c'est un moyen
de lever des financements j'en prends
pas de finances forme ces sociétés de
projets font appel pour gps au tout
n'est pas encore stabilisé
puisque les élus locaux ont souhaité
attendre
dans lordonnance nous avons respecté
leur choix mais effectivement c'est un
modèle
qui je pense
fès a fait ses preuves et mérite sans
doute d'être prise en tout cas je ne me
vois pas à ce stade d'obstacles ou en
tout cas de nécessité de changer le
la direction sur les légers perso je
finis avec sap ce sénateur bon
jeudi deux choses d'abord le tout ce que
j'essayais comprend bien la branche
jusqu'à dax
camp sinon le conseil régional de
nouvelles aquitaine n'est pas signé bon
et vous avez raison il ya 20% vous avez
dure au moins 20% sera pas mal de
financements européens qui sont attendus
vous avez sans doute lu comme moi
puisque vous avez fait référence ces
décisions annoncées par l'europe sur ces
1 % la décision il était tout à fait
normal que j'ai pesos ne figura points
dans ce train fixe beard annonce puisque
était ciblé des aux personnes dont les
travaux étaient engagés sur le point de
l'être ce qui est hélas hélas même si
j'ai accélérez n'est pas encore tout à
fait le cas de gpso donc il ya
d'ailleurs eu une communication assez
précise que vous avez sans doute vu
émanant du préfet coordonnateur le
préfet de région occitanie suite cette
décision qui explique y compris les
relations et les déclarations qui ont
été faites du côté de l'europe bon
maintenant soyons clairs vous êtes
toutes et tous ici suffisamment
expérimentés ou sait très bien que rien
n'est jamais gagné s'agissant des
financements européens et là où vous
avez parfaitement raison c'est
qu'effectivement
l'objectif non seulement c'est dax mais
c'est l'espagne c'est encore plus plus
vers le sud et le pays basque et je n'ai
pas ici évoquer les réticences comme ce
qu'a remarqué notamment la la
collectivité vasque sur
l'arrivée du lgv en site propre en tout
cas jusqu'à la frontière espagnole mais
oui tout se fait à dire sur tout sujet
qu'on va prendre sur tout sujet il ya
des incertitudes il ya et c'est bon
c'est personne ne peut le masque et vous
avez tous y compris dans vos vies d'élus
mener des projets il ya toujours des
aléas et d incertitudes
mais encore une fois je je ne regrette
pas les avancées je vous le dit voilà il
ya des bordeaux est bien desservi
désormais et ce à mobiliser des
financements de collectivités plus au
sud donc il est normal de poursuivre
vers toulouse et vers la frontière
espagnole me semble-t-il vous avez
monsieur c'est aussi c'est vous qui avez
vous qu'est des contentieux autoroutier
bon c'est un vrai sujet ça nous renvoie
la question des recettes évoquée par le
le rapporteur vous connaissez tous
l'histoire de la loi de finances pour
2020 qui a repris l'indexation
alors que les sociétés d'autoroutes
considère que l'accord qu'elles devaient
trouver je crois du temps où madame
royal
disait que ll conditionnelle leur
contribution volontaire entre guillemets
à une stabilité de ce prélèvement bon
donc il est néanmoins de la seule chose
que je veux dire nous avons essayé
réunir les instances de conciliation il
ya eu je sais plus exactement devenu
forme d'arbitrage qui sont réunis en
2021 mais de fait sans à vous dire ah
d'accord ce qui est regrettable
évidemment bon du coup lagence a émis
des titres de recettes ce que les
sociétés d'autoroutes ont contesté c'est
devant des tribunaux et il y aura au
moins si j'ai bien compris une première
décision qui devrait être rendu à la fin
de l'été mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle
vous satisfasse que vous satisfasse
qu'elle réponde au fond à votre question
puisque si j'ai bien compris c'est un
déclinatoire de compétences des rôles
année encore à savoir qu'elle le 6e la
juridiction de l'ordre judiciaire ou la
juridiction de l'ordre administratif qui
est compétente pour connaître de ce
contentieux
mon intention c'est à terre pour aller
au bout
c'est d'essayer d'apporter ma
contribution à ce que les discussions
puissent reprendre avec les sociétés
d'autoroutes crois qu'il faut laisser
pour préserver les intérêts de l'état le
contentieux se poursuivre
mais évidemment il est de l'intérêt de
l'agent ce dont j'aurais à des femmes
des intérêts si je suis désigné
président
voilà que cette affaire se soldent je
crois quand même que cette contribution
c'est un jeu de 100 millions par an
on est loin des montants que vous avez
cités m'enfin dans le panier de recettes
que j'évoquais elle n'est pas tout à
fait neutre et elle renvoie aux
principes plusieurs secteurs ont évoqué
dire c'est l'illustration un peu du
financement de de la route vers l'e
mobilité durable et des transports
décarbonés donc au delà même des
montants je crois qu'il ya une valeur
symbolique forte qui s'attache à la
résolution de ce de cette question
est oui madame la sénatrice sans doute
faudra-t-il je ne sais pas s'ils
existent je ne le crois pas que l'
agence est d'abord une stratégie pour la
prise en compte
du changement climatique
en premier lieu je pense que ça passe
aussi par les choix technologiques sur
les nouveaux projets et qui sont
évidemment très important et on revient
aussi aux questions de de
régénération
et on le retrouvera aussi en fait c'est
une des dimensions
du
du kop de la sncf réseau qui a une taxe
spécifique sur la prise en compte du
changement climatique et pour être tout
à fait avec honnête avec vous ce que
vous avez d'écrire sur le passage de
quatre à deux pas du canal seine nord
europe là je je ne laisse pas au courant
donc je voudrais pas vous dire de
bêtises donc je ne peux pas je vais je
vais creuser la question je viens devant
vous mais je ne peux pas y répondre en
l'état madame la sénatrice
sur la wii wheel fajardo pardon excusez
moi tout à fait t'as fait ruer et
même réponse qu'à votre collègue jeunes
j'ignore si vous me demandez s'il existe
ne une stratégie sur les nuisances
sonores corps est élaboré lagence je ne
le sais pas dite raisonnée tu vois je
mais je vais regarder attentivement
cette question ayant été confronté à feu
j'ai par ailleurs je pense que c'est une
vraie question pardon à massat
merci et c'est une très bonne question
parce que c'est une question qui est
souvent posée
parce que c'est vrai que ça ça pose un
grand nombre de problèmes bon comme il
est et 12h51 disent que je vais faire il
reste encore dix ou onze demandes de
parole je vais vous donner tous sa
parole si vous pouvez poser vos
questions d'une façon assez rapide ce
serait bien
moi ça me dérange pas un mais ce qu'on
soit là encore à 15h ce camp des
questions d'actualité j'ai dans ma
parole à rémy pointereau oui merci
monsieur le président on répond dans ma
voisine
le bien ne fait pas de bruit une prix ne
fait pas de bien c'est vrai que
les questions s'épuise un peu avec
évidemment le nombre de questions qui
ont été posées moi je voulais simplement
revenir sur le le rapport monsieur
premier ministe sur le rapport dernier
rapport du coi
qui a rappelé que la wii sur la période
2018 2022 le total des engagements
s'élever à 15 milliards d'euros par an
en additionnant l'effort de l'état de la
fif des collectivités territoriales de
la société du grand paris de sncf réseau
et ce rapport estime
selon ses attentes en termes
d'investissements pour les deux période
2023 2028 et 2038 2028 2032 à plus de 22
milliards d'euros par an
et donc il faudrait trouver 7 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires par an
[Musique]
alors soit par l' agence de financement
ou d'autres collectivités
moi ce que je voulais vous dire d'abord
j'ai apprécié votre position équilibrée
sur la volonté de traiter à la fois la
modernisation du réseau existant mais
également des lignes nouvelles je suis
très heureux pour nice pour toulouse
perpignan mais il faut savoir qu'il ya
aussi encore des territoires oubliés
comme dans le grand centre auvergne où
il ya un vrai sujet et vous avez dit
tout à l'heure que 45% des crédits ont
été consacrés au ferroviaire dans les
crédits je pense qu' il faudrait
peut-être aller au delà
vous avez évoqué également le problème
des recettes parce que c'est le nerf de
la guerre si on veut aller plus loin et
vous avez dit également qu'il y avait
des démarches d'amélioration
et qui faudrait peut-être trouver une
ressource affectée
sinon il faudra aller vers les
contributions supplémentaires de l'état
des collectivités
moi j'aurais quand même rappeler que
dans un contexte où l'argent va être de
plus en plus rares
pour l'état mais aussi pour les
collectivités à qui on va demander de
faire un effort supplémentaire
et avec la volonté de l'engagement de
l'objectif gouvernemental d'aller vers
2025 pour avoir l'obligation des
critères européens
d'être dans les 3,1 pour cent ou 3% du
déficit public inférieur du pib et 60%
de la dette publique inférieure à 60%
pour du pib est ce que vous pensez pas
que de leurs vous avez parlé d'un mur
d'investissements qu'on risque de sa
risque pas de devenir un mur
infranchissable notre super ministre
si j'avais un parole à françois calvet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
je me réjouis particulièrement
sachant
vous l'avez prouvé
thème aux fonctions de premier ministre
mais bien avant sur notre territoire des
pyrénées orientales votre attachement
aux infrastructures de transport et donc
moi je me réjouis de cette candidature
de cette proposition qui vous est faite
de devenir donc
président de cette agence
je voudrais juste deux mots bien sûr
j'ai du mal à oublier le chaînon
manquant montpellier perpignan mes
collègues en voudraient si je ne le
sentais pas mais
d'abord je vous remercie pour l'avancé
vous avez concrétiser
au mois de janvier février avec la
présidente de la région à narbonne
sur le la partie de transport
montpellier béziers mais à cette
occasion on a parlé beaucoup d'argent
moi je voudrais parler de procédure moi
je trouve que dans tous les projets
d'intérêt national nous avons souvent
des procédures extrêmement longues qui
font que quand on me fixe un coup de
départ et au moment où elle réalise on
paie deux ou trois fois il faudrait
peut-être expliquer aux contribuables
qu'à un moment donné ce sont des
emprunts que nous faisons et ce sont des
dettes
même s'il ya des recettes par ailleurs
que nous générons et je me disais que
est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas c'est pas
tout à fait le rouge mais quand même
elle peut contribuer à porter cette
pierre pour le démontrer est-ce qu'on ne
pourrait pas par exemple utiliser les
procédures que vous aviez vous même
su gérer pourrait que nous avons voté
pour les jeux olympiques les procédures
allégées qui permettrait puisque tout le
monde est d'accord pour la transition
écologique est ce qu'on ne peut pas
allégé procédure qui pourrait gagner
l'argent mais permettrait d'aller sur
vont plus loin première chose deuxième
chose sur la nationale 116 qui est un
exemple important pour nous bon là aussi
vous avez
générer plus de 72 millions de travaux
donc c'est très important le programme
qui va être fait et ce passage des
routes nationales aux régions et aux
départements
qui est suggéré dans la loi 3ds que vous
avez porté moi je voudrais que ça
s'accélère parce que c'est le seul moyen
ce sont des routes
franchement moi je suis parlementaire
depuis
1993 je vois que ça n'avance en l'état
ne s'intéressent pas particulièrement
9000 kilomètres un gros de route
nationale il faut bien dire la vérité et
donc est ce qu'on ne peut pas faire des
routes d'intérêt régional fait faire les
choses qui permettent enfin de faire
avancer ce que ce que vous avez fait
comme expérience en occitanie pourrait
peut-être faire l'objet de données
agissements important car sans ça nous
non notre milieu rural notre milieu de
montagne ne verra jamais le véritable
désenclavement merci monsieur merci la
parole et à bruno belin
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre d'abord à titre
personnel ravi de vous retrouver merci
pour vos propos sur les routes ça fait
la jonction exclamé françois vient de
dire surtout vous avez cité les routes
notamment je cite en milieu rural et
donc puisque je me permets une petite
page locale nous n'oublions pas la 147 à
149 la poitiers limoges dont il ya
longtemps que nous en parlons ensemble
pour ma part je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur la sécurité des ponts et
des ouvrages d'art vous le savez notre
commission s'intéresse de longue date à
ce sujet notamment suite au drame de
gènes avec deux rapports publiés en 2019
et l'autre le mois dernier je vous
rappelle mesure remise que nous ne
savons toujours pas combien de points 12
ouvrages d'art en france 210 milles à
250 milles et que le gap et et grands la
situation nous inquiète au plus haut
point qu'à la dégradation de l'état de
nos ponts se poursuit ainsi nous avons
estimé que 7% des pontes delta sont en
mauvais état structurelles 10% des pans
départementaux et environ 20% des ponts
communaux soit un total d'environ 30 à
35 mille ouvrages en mauvais état
structurelles et vous imaginez que les
communes rurales n'ont ni les moyens
financiers ni les moyens techniques
humains de s'y intéresser les moyens mis
par l'état s'ils ont augmenté
ne sont pas encore à la hauteur pour
enrayer la spirale de dégradation de nos
ponts l'appui apporté par le ser emma
est aussi déterminant est chouette
qu'ils puissent effectivement apparaître
comme sans doute assistant à maîtrise
d'ouvragé mais on s'inquiète des moyens
qui seront proposées aux collectivités
la fidh propose dispose pardon de
crédits d'entretien spécialisés de
maintenance des ouvrages d'art du réseau
routier national non concédé c'est à
dire ceux du réseau routier qui relève
de l'état mais pas pour soutenir
ceux des collectivités territoriales
donc deux questions d'abord quelle est
la trajectoire prévisionnelle des
crédits de laffitte sur l'entretien
spécialisés des ouvrages d'art qui
relèvent de sa compétence
est-ce que ce qui a été imaginée
c'est-à-dire 145 millions d'euros en
2027 va dans ce sens et puis comment la
fuite pourrait soutenir apporter son
soutien aux collectivités locales sur
cette problématique
voilà nous comptons continuer à
travailler sur ce sujet sans doute par
le dépôt d'une proposition de loi et
nous souhaitons pouvoir compter sur
votre expérience car l'édifice sur cette
question des ponts et ouvrages d'art qui
nécessite de nombreux investissements
est essentiel merci monsieur le premier
ministre merci la parole à guillaume
chevrollier merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre vous avez
beaucoup parlé de la décarbonation de la
mobilité est évidemment un sujet majeur
fonds pensez vous que les
investissements aujourd'hui de de la
fuite sont ils suffisants pour respecter
tous les les objectifs européens que
récent que ce soit le paquet a justement
l'objectif 55 le paquet mobilité durable
et efficiente nous pour respecter nos
objectifs européens et surtout dans dans
les délais ma deuxième question était
sur la sécurité des ponts mais vient
d'être posée par le rapporteur bruno
belin donc j'ai tout de suite à la
troisième vous l'avez évoqué sur la fin
des concessions
autoroutières la première en 2031 et une
autre en 2036 savez qu'il ya un rapport
sénatorial qui a qu'à pointer un niveau
élevé de rentabilité
hors norme ça a été rappelé par par ce
rapport donc vous avez évoqué vous mais
même si ces lointains mais qu'est ce que
vous attendez de ces négociations pour
les financements de la fit et et vous à
titre personnel pensez vous que les
versements des sociétés concessionnaires
à lafitte doivent-ils être augmentée
pour permettre justement d'alimenter le
le panic vous avez également parlé merci
merci je n'ai apparemment là joël bigot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le candidat je
vous parlais de des autoroutes la fin
des contrats de concession autoroutière
arrive à grands pas il ya toujours pas
eu de véritable préparation comme l'a
démontré
l'europe la commission d' enquête
sénatoriale 2020 préparation pour la
presse or il nous faut absolument
l'anticiper c'est l'objectif de la
proposition de résolution qui avait été
déposé par mon collègue olivier jacquin
groupe socialiste en février dernier qui
proposait de créer un établissement
public qui aurait vocation à gérer
l'ensemble du réseau routier non concédé
puis les autoroutes à la fin des
contrats de concession en mutualisant
les ressources des financements seraient
ainsi dégagé pour rénover un réseau
routier non concédé qui en a grand
besoin bien sûr la fin des concessions
signifiant la fin des péages des
redevances devront être instaurée comme
des éco taxe poids lourds qui viendrait
alimenter les recettes de la fit et par
ricochet le ferroviaire et le fluvial
permettant donc d'après d'appliquer le
principe pollueur payeur vous nous
disiez tout à l'heure qui veulent aller
falloir être imaginatif et trouver des
ressources affectées monsieur le premier
ministre et candidat que pensez vous de
cette idée
merci la parole est à angèle préville
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre donc je vais vous intéresse je
vais vous questionner sur la nouvelle
ressource affectée et sur peut-être la
nécessité qu'il y aurait d'avoir une
cohérence voire de la logique pour
qu'elles soient bien comprises par tous
nos concitoyens à chercher là où il y a
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
importante et dans la dynamique de
favoriser les transports qui sont plus
vertueux le ferroviaire de tous les
jours est encore à la peine notamment
dans mon département les mobilités ne
peuvent pas pour l'instant comme vous
l'avez dit se passer hors voitures il
nous faut absolument développer de plus
en plus c'est beaucoup plus qu'on ne l'a
fait jusqu'à présent rénové avoir de
nouvelles lignes et cela a pour
permettre à tout le monde de nos
seulement de se déplacer au quotidien
mais également de partir en vacances il
a donc un rôle social et notamment
l'euro social qu'on doit avoir de
provoquer des changements massifs
d'habitude de transport sinon nous
n'arriverons pas à juguler et les gaz à
effet de serre les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et on sait que le
transport et pour le tiers dans ses
émissions que l'on doit absolument
diminuer
dans ce cas dans ce cadre là les projets
les contrats de plan état région sont
extrêmement importants donc quel regard
portez vous sur ce que je viens de
mettre en évidence sur la cohérence
qu'on doit avoir sur la nouvelle
ressource affectée et également sur les
biens les les dynamiques qu'on doit
impulser sur les territoires afin que
tout le monde change vraiment
massivement ses habitudes de transport
merci merci la parole est à jean michel
houde merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre vous êtes
un lecteur assidu de la vie du rail le
dernier numéro de la vie du rail met en
exergue un élément nouveau qui est tout
simplement le retour de l'inflation or
le retour de l'inflation sur 2 milliards
7 avec 5,8 pour cent par an ça fait 150
plus de 150 millions qui s'évapore lors
d'une réunion du comité des parties
prenantes donc luc lallemand le pdg de
sncf réseau confirmé d'une part que le
niveau des investissements prévus dans
le contrat de performance à hauteur de 2
milliards 8 n'était pas suffisant alors
que les besoins sont estimés à trois
milliards 7 mais pire encore il dit que
l'inflation va avoir des conséquences et
que la sncf va être conduite à des
mesures d'arbitrage or ces mesures
d'arbitrage elles vont consister tout
simplement à réduire le périmètre
d'intervention il déclare si l'état
n'intervient pas au plus tard en
septembre il faudra diviser le réseau en
deux parties d'un côté le réseau
structurant qui regroupe les lignes
ulysse et 2 à 4 sur lequel la sncf
continuera à investir et puis les autres
c'est-à-dire les le réseau us et 5 à 6
sur lesquels nous allons désinvestir
donc quelle est votre réaction par
rapport à cette décision annoncée de
sncf réseau et puis d'une certaine notre
façon comment allez vous gérer ce
problème d'inflation qui diminue d'une
certaine façon mécaniquement les
recettes de lafitte merci la parole la
parole était rigole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ma question sera rapide parce qu'elle
rejoint celle de collègues qui m'ont
précédé notamment stéphane demilly dans
le domaine ferroviaire et le premier
poste des engagements les interventions
de l'agencé depuis 2014 l' agence
intervient également dans le
renouvellement et la modernisation des
trains des terrils équilibre des
territoires fnrt était alors vous allez
arriver à la tête de la fit avec des
promesses qui ont été lancés y compris
par votre gouvernement pour régénérer
les lignes tht et je pense notamment
même si c'était pas ici pour parler
d'une particulière aux paris clermont
dont les passagers du 19 juillet ont mis
20 heures pour effectuer le trajet au
lieu de 3 heures 30 donc monsieur le
premier ministre en quoi serez vous à la
tête de l' agence l'homme de la
situation c'est à dire celui qui
permettra ce qui n'a pas été fait depuis
plus de 30 ans à savoir la mise à niveau
rapide de certaines infrastructures
ferroviaires
infrastructures ferroviaires défaillante
et qui nécessitent des financements
souvent supplémentaire à ce qui a été
annoncé jusqu'à lors
j'ai bien parole à renard 20 cac oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur
premise d'abord en quelques mots
soulignés ce qu'a dit tout à l'heure
martine filleul en 2050 la france aura
des températures de plus 4 degrés par
rapport à la période préindustrielle
ça n'est absolument pas intégré
aujourd'hui dans nos investissements
d'infrastructure y compris simplement
sur les enrober les bitumes 1 donc je
pense que là vous avez un une urgence de
faire en sorte que les préconisations
techniques mais ça va vous coûter 10 ou
intègrent ce qui est totalement
inéluctable au vu des engagements des
états sur le climat deux questions aussi
rapidement alors la question des
recettes est évidemment centrale vous
avez dit mais je sais pas si le
proposera après 6 à bercy sauriez pour
des recettes fléché ski quand même pas
la logique de l'état en général
dans ses recettes fléchard des d'abord
un petit point concernant la taxe chirac
elle est rien puisque c'est un moment
que j'avais déposé qui avait été refusé
au sénat mais qui a été repris par le
gouvernement qui fait que cette année vu
la reprise du trafic aérien vous pouvez
quand même escompté entre 100 et 200
millions d'euros de recettes et dire qu
en angleterre où les en grande bretagne
où les taxes sont beaucoup plus
importantes sur l'aérien c'est quand
même plus de 3 milliards c'est un peu la
somme dont on parlait tout à l'heure qui
sont pris sur le transport aérien et qui
bourre sur le budget général donc si
vous cherchez une recette affectés je
vous soutiendrai si vous défendez en
tant qu'homme d' influence puisque vous
n'êtes plus l'état d'aller dans ce sens
là mais donc la question c'est
effectivement et c'est une s'arroge dans
les questions précédentes
où est ce que votre lobbing utiliser ce
terme votre capacité d'influencé va
s'exercer sur ces fameux recettes
affectées dont on a besoin on parlait de
l'écotaxe en transport aérien on a quand
même besoin d'avoir peut-être une idée
même si vous ne voulez certainement pas
des volets toutes vos batteries sur
verre où vous allez allez sur ses
recettes affectées dont on a grandement
besoin et l'autre question je vous ai
bien entendu sur le transport en grande
vitesse très fléché comme un vers le sud
de la france quasiment de bordeaux alice
ça balaye à peu près tout le grand sud
mais l'ouest on pourrait parler la
normandie c'est le breton qui parle des
normands on pourrait on parle du massif
central on a l'impression quand même que
la les investissements sont moins ce qui
n'était pas une mauvaise chose farandou
était très clair en disant aux brestois
et aucun perron rêvez pas vous n'aurez
pas ma ligne à grande vitesse était
peut-être temps de dire aux bretons
qu'ils perdaient l'énergie pour rien
alors qu'ils ont d'autres enjeux sur le
sur le ferroviaire mais on voit bien
donc un vous avez confirmé tout à
l'heure cette priorité sur la grande vie
vers le sud ce qui veut dire qu'il ya
d'autres choses qu'on ne fera pas soit
d'autre grande vitesse c'est pas trop
mon propos mais surtout on est
extrêmement en retard la 1000 de rungis
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure sur la
question des ports français et de
l'offre ferroviaire en sortie de port
qui est une des grandes faiblesses
françaises c'est extrêmement cher
d'avoir un vrai maillage
de transports combinés d'offres
containers à l'est celle de tous les
ports français c'est nord - une urgence
mais je l'ait pas entendu comme une
priorité pour vous sur les toutes
prochaines années
la parole est à fabia jeunes et puis
pour clore nicole bonnefoy
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre candidat je suis à
votre gauche
paris six jeux au moins dans cette salle
je pense que notre commission de se ré
pouvoir se prononcer sur votre
candidature sans vous donnez l'occasion
de dire un mot de la route centre europe
atlantique qui est au niveau des
infrastructures routières de notre pays
un un élément extrêmement important de
par sa dangerosité vous êtes venu sur le
terrain il y a quelques mois pour
garantir les financements nécessaires
comme premier ministre alors ma question
sera simple est ce que comme président
de laffitte vous poursuivrez l'oeuvre
qui était la vôtre comme premier
ministre et puisque vous vous
interrogiez monsieur le premier ministre
pour savoir si vous seriez toujours
président de laffitte en 2030 2031
puisqu'on parle d'agenda est-ce que vous
pouvez garantir que comme président de
laffitte vous serez à l'inauguration de
la mise à deux fois deux voies de la
totalité du linéaire de la route centre
europe atlantique ce qui vous permettra
ensuite de pouvoir vous intéresser aux
lignes ferroviaires en saône et loire et
en particulier la kz paray-le-monial
lyon qui est un enjeu est également très
importante je vous remercie
merci on est déjà à période inauguration
la parole est à nicole bonnefoy bien
après monsieur comédie je laisserais
répondre avant que nous puissions passer
au vote en plo collègues nous quitte oui
et mercier le seul président monsieur le
premier ministre mama ma question
concernera le l'augmentation incessante
du trafic routier de marchandises sur
qui traverse donc notre pays et qui
utilise pour partie les autoroutes mais
qui peuvent tout à fait parce qu'il y a
des routes nationales ou un réseau
secondaire parfaitement adaptés quitter
ses autoroutes et utiliser ces routes
secondaires avec des conséquences parce
que ce sont au fond et je le vois dans
mon département avec la route nationale
10 une autoroute gratuite qui maintenant
est empruntée majoritairement par les
camions avec des conséquences évidemment
dramatique sur le plan de la sécurité de
la sécurité routière sur le plan des
pollutions de tous ordres et sur le plan
également du coût de l'entretien des
dites route 1 et donc ça ça doivent
évidemment vous parler puisque
régulièrement évidemment il faut
effectuer des travaux sur ces routes
donc le sénat a fait déjà fait remarquer
ce type de situation depuis un moment à
fait différentes propositions jusqu'à
présent elles n'ont pas été retenues
et je voudrais donc je profite de
l'occasion pour évoquer ce sujet avec
vous et voir ce que vous en pensez et
puisqu'on parlait des autoroutes et des
contrat de concession des autoroutes il
serait peut-être intéressant de voir
avec les sociétés de gestion
d'autoroutes des tarifs particuliers
pour le transport international de
manière à ce que les camions qui
traversent la france reste sur
l'autoroute quand elles peuvent y rester
au lieu d'emprunter le réseau secondaire
en tout cas c'est un vrai sujet merci
merci une précision de notre collègue
philippe tabarot 10 secondes pour mes
collègues leur rappeler parce que je les
vois un peu envieux que la ligne
nouvelle provence côte d'azur n'est pas
une ligne à grande vitesse c'est une
ligne pour améliorer le transport du
quotidien sur le réseau le plus vétustes
de france merci
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
laisse le soin de répondre à mes
collègues merci tu as bien je confirme
évidemment la dernière intervention mais
on tient à votre disposition la
convention que nous avons signée avec
les collectivités territoriales
et je dis évidemment que l'on peut
toujours m'inviter aux inaugurations
après ça marche toujours voyez par
exemple encore il ya quelques jours je
suis allé poser la première pierre d'un
pont
du côté du lot-et-garonne que nous
avions écouté le financement lorsque
j'étais premise pas de problème
voilà bon c'est très bon projet la r je
le dis je je revendique devant vaud n'a
pas parlé parce que je pourrais vous
parler de de la mise à deux fois deux
voies dalle auriol dans la drôme de la
rn124 de la déviation de vedène fax et
dans la meuse bon oui on a nagé
accélérer des projets routiers dit je
revendique que devant vous et je les
fais en prenant alors des fois parce que
il y avait des maîtrises d'ouvragé
départementale
ce n'étaient pas que des routes
nationales et je vous le signale siècle
cela il vérifiera tout ça le moment venu
en prenant sur des enveloppes fnadt donc
c'est à dire en allant chercher des
moyens supplémentaires à ce que ans le
grand cela fift mobilisent et je le
regrette pas d'avoir fait il y avait il
y avait une condition préalable ça
rejoint un peu là votre question sur les
divisent les jets d'ailleurs moi je ne
pas accélérer pas pu le faire pour 1 116
que vous le savez bien les projets
déclarés d'utilité publique avec toi
dans le temps court qui est le mien va
pas rouvrir un gps mais je perçoive un
immense avantage par rapport à d'autres
hauts normands que vous évoquez
rassurez-vous ici et en tome c'est que
s'est déclarée d'utilité publique par le
conseil d'état et que la déclaration
d'utilité publique il était à la fois
définitive et vous le savez en serre et
enfin où sa validité enserré dans un
délai bon donc pareil pour les projets
routiers jeu r cela faisait
effectivement partie de ceux-là 1 on
peut aussi parler de du contournement de
serge pas si j'ai cité qui était
déclarée d'utilité publique donc
j'ai essayé de les de les accélérer bon
sur le fond il ya plusieurs questions
qui ce qui se raccorde enfants tournent
autour j'allais dire depuis le début de
cette audition
même si cointreau me dit oui à un mur
d'investissements la formule n'est pas
de moi un je crois je crois qu'elle est
dû du coi du président ainsi j'ai bien
lu bon mais bon elle a le mérite d'être
images et d'être illustrative weaver on
a beaucoup d'investissements affaires on
a des finances publiques qui ne sont pas
guillerette qui sont en difficulté voilà
senna il faut qu'on soit cohérent 1 on
ne peut pas
hémisphère
prenait si vous voulez droite ou gauche
dira faut absolument investir là dedans
ce matin nous parlons de mobilité il ya
il faut absolument restaurer les
finances publiques à un moment où il va
falloir mettre de l'ordre et voilà est
exactement donc ça alors moi je plaide
pourquoi je suis devant vous c'est parce
que je pense je l' ai déjà dit certes
sommairement et je m'en excuse auprès de
vous à mon propos introductif mais nous
sommes si on fait des bons choix
d'investissement 1 sur des sujets
absolument inévitable compte tenu du
changement climatique et de la
transition écologique et de sion en
retour sur investissement nous ne
parlons pas aurait plus de dépenses de
fonctionnement de notre sujet donc je
plaiderai en tout cas mais à la place
qui est désormais la mienne qui n'est
plus décisionnel mais je plaiderai
effectivement pour que nous puissions
franchir le mur investissement qui comme
l'a fort bien il sera porteur de toute
façon à aboutir à des compromis à des
cote mal taillée et cetera s'il faut se
veut respirer c'est que nous ne passions
pas la marche arrière une dynamique a
été insufflé donc on peut reconnaître
tous elle est insuffisante je le
reconnais y compris avec ma casquette
dans le symbolisme bien volontiers donc
il faut absolument
donc ça renvoie je ne vous je ne oui je
le sénateur c'est vrai que bercy n'aime
pas les recettes affectées m'a fait ça
vous n'avez pas je pense besoin d'un
cadre bonne audition pour savoir ça et
oui je considère devant vous en ma
qualité cette fois ci de deux candidats
que après il ya des grands débats les
écotaxes a fait l'amour vous voyez tous
aussi les inconvénients les vous
connaissez tout ça vous l'avez vécu
parfois dans votre chair dans nos
territoires bon mais je pense
effectivement que les recettes affectées
je n'invente rien sont la meilleure
garantie de
sanctuariser je sais pas lequel d'entre
vous empressez terme je me retrouve
parfaitement faux la meilleure façon
sanctuary zay havrais après il y aura
des choix à faire dans les priorités
voilà j'ai bien entendu je m'entends du
oui mais on veut moins de lgv en règle
générale ceux qui en veulent moins c'est
ce qu'ils sont déjà desservies spa pour
grands classiques d'hier n'y a pas de
route que du ferroviaire je vous ai dit
modestement la vision équilibrée mais
encore une fois c'est vous mesdames et
messieurs les élus désormais fait
désormais par rapport à ce que je sais
moi qui aurait la main qu'ils
continueraient à la voir on va avoir des
choix à faire le gouvernement et le
parlement pourrons-nous franchir le mur
d'investissements en tout cas sûrement
si je vous dit sûrement pas la hauteur
du recensement exhaustif des besoins qui
se sont exprimés mais en tout cas il
faut pas ou pas sera la ligne c'est le
trail des mois à venir mais il faut
absolument à la fois par la sécurisation
des recettes et par la détermination des
priorités que nous poursuivions nous
amplifions les investissements dans ce
domaine parce que vraiment je le croyais
il en va de notre réussite de la
transition écologique et comme c'est une
des priorités fixées par le président de
la république bien je je pousserai de
tout mais force ce qui me concerne pour
que nous arrivions le plus dur comme
encore une fois ce sera de faire des
choix parce qu'on ne doit pas tout faire
mais sans le sait mais c'est notre sel
collectif si je perds un mobile est sur
les ponts vinci c'est un sujet mais
enfin je veux répondre les ponts bon oui
alors j'adore ça va c'est ce que dit
bruno 1 on me dit qu'un entre 200 et 250
milles ce qui est quand même pas d'une
précision horlogère bon
mais alors ce qui est bien quand même
c'est que dans le plan de relance ça je
me souviens de ça on a mais vous l'avez
rappelé inscrit 46 millions
justement pour permettre d'avoir un
diagnostic fin c'est déjà ça bon et on
m'indique je pense que vous aviez cette
information que 5000 maires ont déjà
reçu un carnet de santé de leur ouvrage
très bien voilà mais enfin il y en a
quand même aux mire qu'il avait demandé
donc si j'ai bien compté on n'est pas
encore tout à fait à la moitié
certainement pas au bout vous avez
raison bon en tout cas ça c'est pour les
ponts dont les maîtres d'ouvragé des
propriétaires sont les les collectivités
territoriales si je comprends bien les
les commandes hier le dispositif qui est
d'ailleurs piloter mais vous l'avez dit
par le ser et bah c'est sûr le
diagnostic on verra ensuite seul et les
travaux que ce diagnostic ferait
apparaître bon mais pour l'état c'est
fait pour les ports relevant de l'état
alors pour le coup on a parlé des
autoroutes là bon il faut quand même le
dire c'est que les concessions peuvent
aussi avoir des avantages mais monsieur
sénateurs bon sur le réseau non concédé
il en va effectivement différemment et
je dois quand même plus attention et
senna se fait que l'effort budgétaire
qui a été consenti est quand même
important
puisque la trajectoire kireta verts
avaient été retenus comme vous l'avez
dans le cas de la l'homme croît chaque
année de près de 10% pour atteindre si
mes informations sont exactes 120
millions d'euros pour la période 2023
2027 à venir et la programmation
suivante c'est loin de 1028 2032 on
passerait dans les prévisions à 180
millions d'euros donc j'allais dire je
ne sais pas si c'est sur ma faim le
sujet des ponts et quand même
identifié et on voit bien qu'il va
s'inscrire dans la durée que donc il
faudra bien dans les
voiles à des avec déjà des interventions
et travaux commencés les gens voient la
donne et je vous donne une petite
information la commission aux affaires
européennes se réunit à 13h30 il faut
qu'on vote
monsieur le premier ministre en est
l'enjeu majeur bon je suis comme vous à
monsieur si vous me demandez là c'est
jusqu'à 17h ya pas y'a pas de problème
est surtout ces sujets je veux dire
quand maman voisins
que je suis un farouche partisan de
l'allègement évidemment des procédures
que j'avais dit j'ai vu que l'annoncé a
été reprise par le présent la république
que nous espérons effectivement la loi
olympique des impératifs du changement
climatique
et notamment sur le champ énergétique
c'est vrai que c'était plus ce plan des
ressources énergétiques que sur celui
des infrastructures transports mais
devait nous conduire à faire à une loi
d'exception mot est mal connoté m'a fait
montrer que oui fait j'avais lu quelque
part comme vous que les procédures
françaises aboutissent à ce que les
projets dure 20 ou 30% un temps de plus
que dans la moyenne européenne
il ya des choses qui sont difficiles à
corriger mais celle là si on s'y met et
donc voilà alors que le gouvernement
avait l'intention de présenter un texte
à ce sujet sur la rn je dis souvent aux
secteurs que de mémoire la loi 3ds
donnait jusqu'à la fin septembre
aux collectivités alors soit département
soit région on avait un navet bruno
trouver un accord entre arf et adf dans
mon bureau pour choisir de prendre la
maîtrise ouvrages ou de récupérer
donc je
j'avoue ne pas savoir si ou la région ou
le conseil départemental en délibéré
mais enfin je vais suivre ça
est-ce que j'ai d'autres points oui
alors c'est juste si camille comme une
question d'un superbe coup et sur sncf
réseau là est ce que ce qu'a dit le
patron de sncf réseau sur l'inflation
mais chez la raison enfin tous les
maîtrisent les maîtres d'ouvragé publics
savent bien la fille d'un état d'un
financeur en tout cas que l'on va avoir
à tout ce qu'on a dit la haut mur au mur
du mois de février va s'ajouter
l'inflation bon donc le mur va prendre
de brique de plus pour y compris
évidemment pour les travaux de cette
phrase oh comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
dire au patron de sncf réseau
il n'y a pas que l'inflation qui est à
l'origine d'un renchérissement de ses
coûts
propre petit point
cet avenant bonne foi sur l'histoire de
la rn10 et puis l'histoire de
effectivement sur les autoroutes ce qui
peut y avoir une négociation avec les
concessionnaires autoroutiers pour
qu'ils empruntent l'autoroute plutôt que
les routes nationales
alors je je je je dois confesser que je
n'ai pas lu un bonne foi le rapport la
du sénat les propositions que vous avez
formulées à ce sujet mais je vais le
faire voilà peut le faire bien eh bien
merci merci monsieur promelys donc
après cette audition va passer au vote
on vous donnait des bulletins
voter merci